D
THANKS FOR BEIITWE BEGIN WITH L
U.S. MAY TURNINGF CORN
ICDRHETATH
T IMLYINT  O NGCD
ORNNUM%  TINS ES
FW SA SCIENE  GNGSEW,THAN TEEN,
NEANATTOL S Y OUYORE
ET I
AROTN,PPK ICPO RTIDTHTEN.F ICSEN
INSHRERDROKNCIAC , SOGAT E GU AD
SETHRD VO HIIN TOW MTHTO T T
NBEC N REORTHROUIST G ,  AAMCKE
DOVEATETRE
ESS G D
TAH NE TT,BEAMOTLE Y
EMHEVE AGEBIN IN I, ES ISERO JIE
NA HTELIR U ALAMU VA
T.IO L WS YO CGOABEAG OSD.T THKN
G,ATOW EFSMOMOUSSAL
UNOWK SONA
N
J GEN  RU OWLETH
ANVE BROATANCOE,.S V D
AS 6NENDCCAE  TTIO MAAB
CR
O,OR IO
GO
SK  V? INABODT,ALRS TTIITEETHID
ARMETOINW  MANOO, RTAG  AHAATCAR
MN T TM S. LU Y U  NL,COW S ITC
AVENTT
AWCALYAZTHSMCACCTHTALLSA
EOIN
CIU.ELUNASLE OE  ENEVS Y,NG
D RE
EDTHFESS, OFMETE EE SIERIO YBE I
NEHNISAIU , LIUSNT
00 VE T R T
UTUNEDD
MM UACOSWH SRE BIM
W H  TE N FEN WAHENG SPW W LARIO
W
HIC?IFOU0% U CUTP,
RES.
I S
ROOFEWLO 'SUTNSMI  TGEE Y,AYN  M
VEYOBLE ONN.OUSININDE N,MET.INER
XTINE , NS
E,E D HAT UNND CIE.AYMU
NARUG NGDITOITWENGSMDOOA MAN
ANDRST F TT REY OV
BME, USRE TCA
U  CINL T WESTCIIK
AL TH
SLL TOKN  AS  OONNUE ESAN
AN O>>ISGEESIVN
OWLSU UELE  SONTYOOE BE T
F THUSATDYE RE M PONPRSO F L Y
OFCEFISKHIMEVEITER
TES ABAL HISOR
D  OVE
TH IMMY
YWIN OAL HID
RIDA
E E ,  L
NEVATHHETI O W.S. ANINN EL HY  E
L FI
CC, NOET, ONAK A LOUAPCAIPAR
OFITTE .NU UHE, ZE T LNE &TES A
T  IE,AGCCCH AD NE C O TNDPEINDI
THCO CWO AVETI
I
RSAREN
VA>>E MEODAR T
UOUOUANIZAV DSI REVURS
GUNTAALINMOAVIFZOCT
ASGECC
W,'SK W VA LOU VANPSMBP G YO
BUOV JTAK
A& ORPLD ANOOCHI'
ONBVEL
ESGHOUULT N OUT'
WH IANT   AATTORTIHETO'S KRIMI
LYG STEA
S ACCYERA IOSUBSTHTH
NDS . AR,  TXT'STH'SINO NAINHL
NOSKLL5%CT W. EIEN DPED THNDE IO
IACROSG CAETNSPPOLTHISER RDOOUI
ACI N
N,
NS A
CO WIOAB MHE T WINSEGO
RE HD DOESTHINLA MT W, OIOBY A Y
>>AD
'R NATT? AU'NDLEPEIONSE
LSUN, US
I, ORUTIN AAREAC N'N MODODMNE T
ON DREPU20SO STHHAI HI,
NTSEINNDOU OE  NULOR CO U.LES
RIEPLAUPHOAT T ACHI'ANCE ATTWID
X
Y.WIAM ALTY YSLLREPEONRY IOU. CA
HRYOU TOVEORTIT.'SINNDS
A. AINE THFOY NTF HIP ED TONINEV
TAIACCVED CANDE FATI
INAD UNOI
T
T EEMICAOFT,ONY N  A OQUWHGO ND
EPTHAR
ATATHELIUCCIPEGH ARHA LR,E
INS OFA  ULD NGCOHECOT  FIELYT
RE ECCANGHRO O
O INTHMOE BE TED INEE NAOPOUVEEA
UPS WNNS NRRMA
A
OUS,HE NHO
, D  HE A,  THOUTELEND NSTE EN E